Let me give an example of the limited
dynamic range of current cameras.
Here's is an image I took again,
in my home.
Here, basically, a short exposure,
remembering again the concepts of
exposure that we looked at from
exposure triangle and stuff when
we talk about cameras, and here if you
look at it, you should be able to see,
it's a dark scene but outside you
can see a little bit of snow.
I took this picture on you know, one
of the rare snowy days in Atlanta but
it's a short exposure, you can't
see any of the details inside but
look outside, you can see
a lot of snow and brightness.
Same image or same scene,
different exposure values.
Long exposure, of course,
all of the insides are nice and
visible now but
you might think that there's a lot of
overexposure going on at this point and
the details outside are not good.
So this is an underexposed image,
this is an overexposed image.
Underexposed because lots of
pixels did not get any detail,
lots of black pixels here.
Overexposed, a lot of white,
bright pixels.
So you, if you were to build
histograms of these images,
you would start seeing a lot more on
the white pixels and for this one,
you'd see a lot more black pixels.
Again note,
both of them are exactly the same scene.
They are not even
a different time of the day.
They were taken seconds
after each other and
that's the kind of stuff that basically
old cameras give you right now, and
that is a limited dynamic range and
now, of course,
we're interested in its capturing
the range from here to there.
To capture this dynamic range,
we basically need 5-10 million values
to store all the brightness around us.
Remember the luminosity
stuff that I showed you.
The scale information was significant.
Here we want to basically able to
capture all of this in one image.
Problem is, and recall when we started
talking about images, most images
capture each of the three different
channels in basic 8 bit images,
values of 0 to 255, sometime basically
just put in values of 0 to 1.0 but
again, there are only
256 values as opposed
to a much brighter range that would
cover the range from here to there.
Nowhere close to, of course, being able
to capture 5 to 10 million values.
Just to showcase this,
let's look at this example again.
Here, if you notice,
I'm showing you the high dynamic range.
In the real world, this was a dynamic
range from 10 raised to minus 6 to 10
raised to 6, and
that's what we're trying to look at.
Of course, on a photograph, what we
would most likely do is just showcase
this one and
that's what basically is shown here.
I'm basically showing all the values
that are much more on the brighter side
and focusing it here.
The other end of the spectrum is
the long exposure and of course,
this is the long exposure, and mention
again a lot more bright values and
here what we'll be doing in this dynamic
range is most probably just capture
the region here and
pack it into my 0 to 255 values.
Again, a lot of detail would be lost.
Here, I'm basically showing you more
of the information on this side of
the spectrum.